you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with author and historian peter
francapan and the financial times
political journalist jasmine cameron
jalashi so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
our shining star that's the lead
headline in the sun after the death of
girls allowed singer sarah harding from
cancer at the age of just 39.
the mirror also quotes her mum my
beautiful girl sarah our bright shining
star
the metro leads with the growing row
over plans for tax rises to fund social
care reform and the impact it could have
on young people
while the telegraph reports that three
former chancellors have joined the
criticism of the plan
that's also the lead in the daily mail
while the guardian describes the growing
unrest as nothing less than mutiny
yet according to the times the prime
minister will defy them all and press
ahead with his plans
the financial times leads with what's
shaping up to be a record year for city
mergers and acquisitions almost four
trillion dollars worth of deals so far
so with me tonight author and historian
peter francapan and the financial times
is political journalist jasmine cameron
chileshi welcome to you both uh let's
start with the
metro and that story that i mentioned in
uh the the rundown of the papers there
um the young to pay the price for social
care apparently uh peter
to be able to fund social care in this
country
just to say we just missed the top of
what you said there so if you don't mind
doing a take two
yeah of course so sorry and i think
everybody realizes that a large new
contribution needs to come from
somewhere so the question is where do we
start in bailing out a shop through
economy so i think we've got to think
quite hard about that
the pressure of putting tax on national
insurance and raising tax is it it
passes disproportionately a cost onto
young people
and the result of that is that three
former chancellors are complaining in
public now
about the extent of
where this raid comes from first it's a
manifesto break as as philip hammond has
pointed out and uh that's a that's a
commitment that's been given by the
conservative party at the last election
there have been mutterings to say well
if a manifesto
pledge is going to be broken then maybe
there should be yet another election but
clearly the challenge would be how do
you balance the books and um by taxing
national insurance which effectively is
a tax on jobs
you you suffocate the need and the
ability to be creating jobs particularly
for younger workers particularly
unskilled workers but we should be
incentivizing so it seems that it's the
wrong the wrong way around
and that that revolt that the prime
minister is said to be facing is going
to be a standoff perhaps to deflect some
of the attention away from afghanistan
but right now i think it's about how
economically literate and numerate is
the government and be able to understand
these really big macroeconomic problems
and i think the jury's out on that in
terms of the handling of the last couple
of years but it's the principle
challenge now to get the
the book started balance
meanwhile jasmine we read that three
former chancellors have been critical of
the the plan also
yeah so boris johnson is under quite a
lot of political pressure at the moment
over this issue so it was something that
he pledged to fix when he became pm but
obviously with the pandemic it's really
exacerbated the focus on social care
we've got a situation where we've got an
increasingly aging population but we've
been slashing care funding and so now
the sector's really at a crunch point
and so johnson's in quite a difficult
position because it's clear that
something needs to be done but no one's
no one's clear on what the solutions are
and he's getting a lot of pushback from
within his own party there are some who
are opposed to it on you know
ideological terms they don't believe the
conservatives should be increasing tax
on national insurance they don't like
the idea of breaking a manifesto pledge
they think it sends a really bad message
to the electorate that the party will
break its promises and then there are
others who you know raise concerns about
the fairness of the policy actually
should the cost fall on those who were
younger those who you know have fewer
assets such as houses or those who are
working age and so there's a real
tension between how you solve this you
know this huge crisis and i think
johnson is going to have to convince not
only back ventures but also the public
but if it's going to be the case that
there is a increase in national
insurance and so they're going to be
moved on you know from the individual to
the taxpayer then johnson really needs
to put forward an argument and put
forward his case for that and i do think
overall we need to have you know a
public debate about social care i think
in
cross contrast to the nhs for example
which is deeply ingrained in our social
consciousness we were saving the nhs
clapping for the nhs during the pandemic
i think most people don't really
understand social care and only really
come into contact with it if an elderly
relative needs to use it and so i think
we need a radical overhaul as to how we
think about the sector um peter we here
tonight that the prime minister will be
pushing ahead with his plans despite the
the opposition um how difficult a battle
do you think he's got on his hands come
monday
well jasmine is exactly right that it's
it's how to square the circle you know
the problem is is that i thought that
the polling numbers will be telling uh
boris johnson and the conservative party
that older people tend to vote
conservative and younger people are more
likely to be center-left and therefore
they're not really a constituency that
he's going to worry too much about they
turn out less often in elections but the
way in which the young have been hurt
and hit by cuts education
through with extra funding problems like
the national insurance and other taxes
you know it's a real battle for how this
country gets uh united together we're
split and have been split the last five
or six years around brexit around europe
and not europe and i think this now
between young and old becomes another
issue alongside the north and south
leveling up problems so you know there
are lots of these divisions and the real
question i think is is boris johnson a
prime minister who fundamentally can
unite or is it that kind of trumpian
role of antagonized politics where you
only bring along your own supporters and
you don't really care what the other
side do and that is the sort of the
zeitgeist a lot of democracies right now
not just here in the uk but you need i
think as a prime minister to conciliate
you need to be able to offer fig leaves
you need to listen to criticism and
occasionally back down and i think that
the problem about any prime minister
probably like boris johnson at the
moment if you feel that you're cornered
you know that may not necessarily the
best way to make um constructive
decisions jasmine let's move on to the
telegraph and this story which is going
to be i'm sure i predict a really really
um
tough talking point to do with the 12 to
15 year olds and being vaccinated
children as young as 12 and we're told
will be able to overrule their parents
if they object to them receiving the
vaccine
yeah so this is quite a sensitive topic
because obviously the jcbi last week
they said that they weren't going to
approve vaccinations for the
vast majority of 12 to 15 year olds but
they've left it to the chief medical
officers and so it's still sort of
influx but there are these sort of
practical questions about what happens
if there is a mass rollout of the jab
among you know 12 to 15 year olds and
what play what role parental consent
comes into that and if there's a tension
between what the child wants and you
know what the parent wants and so it's
actually quite a bit of a gray area and
then openly admitting that you know the
priority of the child could potentially
override that of the parent i think
zohar was really opened up a can of
worms because it's something that the
government had been keen to stress you
know parents will be involved in this
decision but in his comments he's sort
of suggesting that actually there is
that bit of tension between parent and
child and i you know i think this is an
issue that we're going to
keep talking about that's going to keep
looming its head um
while we're waiting for a final decision
on this issue well absolutely and the
vaccines minister nazim zahawi said that
if any 12 to 15 year old wants to be
vaccinated and is judged to be competent
then their wishes would override
parental concerns does that shock you
peter
well it tells me that the the thought
only goes in one direction i mean what
happens if 12 to 15 year olds say that
they don't want to get the vaccine i
mean presumably if you have the right to
be able to overrule your parents who are
who are trying to say no what about the
case where parents
want you to have the vaccine and 12 to
15 year olds decide that they don't want
to do it you know i think it opens as
jasmine said a big can of worms you know
one of those questions is about voting
reform as well you know if 12 and 15
year olds are able to make decisions
around their personal health care around
vaccines but what about other areas that
are highly sensitive around personal
health but also around around
participation in other areas i mean so
what does competent who defines it and
who's going to be deemed to be
incompetent so i mean it looks to me
like a sort of a saturday kitchen table
decision that hasn't been thought
through or joined up and you know that's
not particularly reassuring uh to be
trying to to put a comment on i mean i
understand the good the intel the
intents and the purposes of this are
trying to make sure that more people get
vaccinated but that messaging i'm afraid
it's all it's all over the shop here and
jasmine the the metro uh suggesting that
vaccine passports are on their way
according to nadine harvey again
so it's quite an interesting one because
when the notion of vaccine passports was
floated early in the summer it was in
the context of the government being
worried about uptake among the young
particularly the under 30s and there was
this hint that you know maybe it was
just deployed to get the young people to
take the jab but the government seemed
to really sticking to this issue in
spite of you know the inevitable
backbench pushback that they're going to
receive from this and the argument from
the vaccine minister is that actually it
makes business sense they need to find a
way in which businesses especially night
clubs and sort of entertainment venues
or places where you know lots of people
gather need to find ways of making sure
that these businesses can operate in a
covered secure way and so it does seem
to make logical sense on the surface but
i think there are lots of questions
about how this is going to be
practically enforced whether it's a case
of people who need to show
proof of having a jab or whether they
need to show proof of a negative test or
both and so there are lots of questions
surrounding this and it's also unclear
as to how far this policy will actually
extend so the focus at the moment is on
night clubs but you know could it be
sporting venues it seems to be a little
bit vague at the moment and i think the
government are really going to need to
outline some details to the public and
to back ventures and to businesses to
make it clear how this policy can be
implemented on a practical day-to-day
basis